This is a tip that was actually shared with us by a realtor friend of mine.
And he told me, "Just remember the word FORD when you're in a conversation with anyone..."
"...and it will help you spark up conversations."
The way this works is basically just remember the acronym FORD.
F stands for family, so ask people first about their family.
People love to talk about their family.
The O is for occupation.
You can ask them about their job or how their job is going.
R is for recreation, so you can ask them about their hobbies.
People love to talk about that stuff, of course.
And then D is dreams.
So if you always remember that acronym: Family, Occupation, Recreation and Dreams,...
...just remember the word FORD.